[Music]
I don't really like tips it tips about
communicating well tips about writing
when I would prefer is as a process that
transforms you so the tips take place
automatically I mean for instance very
often the tip is given when you're
speaking to a crowd very the pace of
your speech very the volume
well those those are two good things but
if they happen mechanically it gets to
be kind of boring
some people are encouraged when they're
coached at this point leave where you're
standing and walk over there and take a
pause well maybe that makes sense in
terms of how it's written at the end of
that paragraph you want to make a space
before the next paragraph but it doesn't
necessarily make sense in terms of how
you're talking and relating to the
people you're talking with that relating
to them should be the source of a pause
the source of moving because it comes
out of the thought press that process
I'm going through and it comes out of
the thought process I sense you're going
through have you understood that last
part so I'm now I'm thinking if you have
what's the next thing that I can tack on
to that that'll mean something to you
and if you haven't should I clarify it a
little more so there's a dynamic
relationship between us that leads to a
change in pace to a change in volume and
that kind of thing a tip is just an
intellectual ization of that which might
be okay to give somebody once they've
got the the grounding in the the ability
to connect you know it but it ought to
come out of the connection it shouldn't
be a checkbox that you tick off so I
really don't like tips if I'm pressed
really hard there are three tips that I
do kind of follow probably it's a good
idea to follow these tips after you get
used to being connected to somebody but
there are three things
I like to do that I call it the three
rules of three so the first rule is I
try only to say three important things
when I talk to people no more than three
if you can see if it's one thing that's
maybe even better but usually there's a
lot to say but I I'm when I make notes
on what I want to talk about if I say
I'm going on past three to four and five
I start eliminating and we're seeing if
I fold them into the other things
because three things are really all I
can remember and I don't work from notes
when I talk to people and I advise other
people not to I don't never read it
because reading just excommunicates you
it's not communication its
excommunication in my view so I can't
remember more than three things and I
don't think they can remember more than
three things so what's the point of
telling them stuff they're not going to
remember so I stick to through that's
rule number one of through three three
things the second rule is if I have a
difficult thing to understand there's
something I think it's not going to be
that easy to get I try to say it in
three different ways because I think if
you come in from different angles you
have a better chance of making a getting
a three-dimensional view of this
difficult idea so I try to say it three
different ways and the third tip which I
always forget is that if if I have a
difficult thing that that's hard to get
I try to say it three times through the
talk so that the first time you hear it
you start to get used to it the second
time it's familiar in the third time you
say oh yeah yeah right okay
so though no I do follow those three
tips but I don't think I tell somebody
you're going to get up to talk here are
three tips to remember it's a process
you got to get transformed into being a
better communicator you got to go
through steps where it's like going to
the gym only it's a lot more fun than
going to the gym because it involves
connecting with another person and we're
built to connect with another person in
spite of the fact that we often avoid it
it actually is fun when we get into
that position so if we can get ourselves
transformed into liking connecting with
the audience we're talking to or writing
for then these tips will cut will happen
automatically or finally we'll be able
to put them to work in terms of that
transform the way we have of connecting
it really feels good
[Music]